[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
i'm so excited to have my guest today
his name is rich roll and i'm gonna
start
in an unorthodox way and that is by
reading a tweet i don't really do this i
don't know if i've ever done this
but this is a tweet from october 2018
and i think rich is probably going to
see where this is going just before his
52nd birthday
here's the tweet
i didn't reach my athletic peak until i
was 43 i didn't write my first book
until i was 44. i didn't start my
podcast until i was 45. at 30 i thought
my life was over at 52 i know it's just
beginning
keep running never give up and watch
your kites soar
and
then there's actually another tweet
within context so i've retweeted this
for people who want to see it they can
also find it of course at rich roll
r-o-l-l i want to mention one more thing
before we get
to
more of the bio and that is related to
your first half iron man so
this is an outside magazine and here's
the quote in my first half iron man i
barfed during the swim by the time i got
off my bike my legs were so cramped up
that i ran 100 meters
for you yanks like me that's about 300
feet and just stopped it was dnf that
means he did not finish
my beginnings in triathlon were very
humble but i loved it
all right so i'm gonna give this in
drips and drabs but let's let's start
with paragraph one so now zooming out to
present day with a little bit of
retrospective at age 40 ritual like as i
mentioned at ritual on twitter made the
decision to overhaul the sedentary
throes of overweight middle age and i
might i may or may not be in that place
just right now
walking away from a career in law he
reinvented himself as a globally
recognized ultra distance endurance
athlete best-selling author and host of
the wildly popular ritual podcast which
i highly recommend one of the world's
most listened to podcasts with more than
200 million downloads and i'm going to
modify the next paragraph a little bit
rich has been named one of the 25
fittest men in the world by men's
fitness and the
guru of reinvention by outside magazine
he's written a best-selling memoir
finding ultra and has co-authored the
cookbooks slash lifestyle guides the
plant power away and the plant power way
italia with his wife julie is it piat
hyatt damn it i knew i had a 50 50
chance there
it's a common common thing
this is showing where the and how the
sausage is made because a professional
would have asked and in fact i
highlighted her last name to ask you
before we started recording
but you know we live in don't worry
uh just to get a few things mentioned
and we'll mention them again at the very
end ritual.com you can find all things
rich related ritual on all social
including twitter instagram and youtube
except for facebook which is rich role
fans
rich welcome to the show
thanks so much for having me tim it's
it's really an honor to be able to uh
join you for this and i'm really looking
forward to the conversation to come so
thanks for having me yeah absolutely me
too and for those of you who can't see
video
at some point maybe you should check it
out because we have the perfect
yin yang
color template here you have a rather
disheveled tim ferriss in tan with white
background
and rich
looking like a handsome devil with black
clothing black background it's actually
very striking i should request that
guests do this in the future
it will help viewers to keep them
separate so let's let's really dive in
here and i want to establish just a bit
of
background for folks and we're going to
go all over the place
so at age 40 right so you make the
decision to overhaul dot dot
but let's let's get granular and maybe
we could focus on one piece of this life
puzzle which is alcohol
and
could you speak to the role
that alcohol has played in your life
when it entered your life
when you really realized that you had a
problem
let's begin there if you're open to it
it entered my life
uh near the end of high school and the
beginning of college uh prior to that
i was a very studious uh highly
motivated
person who
was very goal driven and that grew out
of i think in retrospect looking back on
my life on a deep insecurity that i had
because as a young person
i was very much an introvert i had a lot
of difficulty
connecting with other people and making
friends i certainly hadn't demonstrated
any kind of like athletic talent or or
ability i was the you know typical like
prototypical kid who gets picked last
for kickball and
was very awkward and self-conscious
and at some point along the way i
discovered the the sport of swimming and
we could talk about that if you like but
that was the one thing where i kind of
felt comfortable and showed some level
of acumen at an early stage and when
you're a young person and you experience
just a little bit of encouragement or
success you're going to kind of double
down on that and that's what i did and i
think there was something about being
underwater
in in almost a metaphysical sense or a
psychological sense where i felt
protected like it was almost like this
womb where
i was insulated from all of the
confusing emotions that i had as a young
person and so swimming really became my
focus
and i realized
early that i wasn't the most talented
kid but i had this capacity to suffer
and to work hard and a willingness to
go the extra mile and with that
sensibility i was able to bridge the
talent deficit gap to some extent
to the point where by the time i was a
senior in high school i was one of the
better swimmers in the washington dc
area where i grew up
and the discipline that i learned in the
swimming pool trickled into
my academic pursuits so i was able to go
from a kid who really had trouble
learning and was sort of a sit in the
back of the class kind of guy
to
being a good student and ultimately
getting into a bunch of fancy colleges
so
so at 18 i really was in a situation a
very privileged situation where the
world was very much my oyster and
anything was possible
but i ended up going to
stanford university i you know i went to
the opposite coast
and i'm sure there's some psychological
reasons why you know i flew 3 000 miles
away to go to college
and it was it was
you know the reason to go there was
twofold i mean first of all stanford is
stanford and it's this amazing academic
institution but at the time
in the mid and late 1980s it also had
the number one nc2a division one men's
swimming program they were like
the most incredible team the most
insane
assemblage of olympic champions and
world and american record holders and
and the like uh and the opportunity to
be a member of that team was like a
dream that i couldn't even imagine for
myself so here i am in this incredibly
privileged situation where anything
truly is possible but enter alcohol
and
alcohol was something that i first was
introduced to when i was doing
recruiting trips and traveling to
colleges which is what you do when
you're you know an athlete and trying to
consider where to go to school and i had
some experiences there that kind of
really anchored in me from moment one
that this was going to be a thing for me
like i had that sensation that you
hear about with
recovering alcoholics where
from the very first drink it was like
this warm blanket that just i could wrap
myself in and all my troubles and fears
and
insecurities just sort of vanished and
for the first time i felt comfortable in
my own skin and i just remember
thinking this is the way that i want to
feel all the time like i could go to a
party and i could strike up a
conversation or crack a joke or talk to
a girl which were all things that were
terrifying to me at the time and so i
just felt like i had found the solution
that i had been looking for my whole
life you know this young person who felt
like everybody else had
a perfect road map for how to live and
suddenly you know those answers that
eluded me were being provided in the
form of this substance and so when i got
to stanford
very quickly well quickly and gradually
but
i would say that i got more and more
progressively more interested in like
where's my next good time
then how am i going to create a
foundation for a happy successful life
and a lot of those aspirations that i
had about
athletics and you know academic
excellence soon became secondary to you
know where's the where's the party
tonight
and it was just a situation where over
an extended period of time like my my
life began to
degrade so it wasn't a situation in
which i created cataclysms out of the
gate that that derailed me
because i could function
and you're it's easier to do that when
you're younger but i could function you
know
i could i could comport myself in a way
where i could still
get good grades show up for class still
you know go out partying until two or
three in the morning and show up for six
a.m swim practice
but over time like this is not a good
recipe for for living and and you know i
lived that way for a very long time
until ultimately things got really dark
and scary and you know i hit that bottom
that you hear about with people in
recovery
what did
any of the bottoms
or dark moments look like if we could
paint a picture of any example that
comes to mind i mean first of all i
would say that there was there was
nothing like cool or rock and roll about
any of it like it's just lonely sad and
and kind of pathetic and and deeply
embarrassing you know just you know i
would i would drive drunk and like
wouldn't remember where i parked my car
and would have to wake up the next
morning and try to figure out where
where my car was when i was living in
san francisco when i was fresh out of
law school
one time i woke up one day didn't want
to go to my law firm job and like flew
to las vegas and lost my wallet and woke
up not remembering anything that had
happened and trying to figure out how
i'm gonna get home
you know stuff like that that's just
you know i was the guy who
who you know was the last to leave the
party and when you're in college you
know maybe it's cute but when you're 25
26 28
um you know nobody's living that way
anymore and you have to find other
people to do that with and like you know
so you you're surrounding yourself with
like what they call lower companions and
the parlance of recovery
until ultimately there's no one left and
you're just alone you know and i was a
guy who would drink alone in my
apartment or
wake up in the morning before work and
and have a vodka tonic in the shower
like it was all very leaving las vegas
and i was only 31 at the time but my
disease had progressed to such a state
where there was really only you know a
couple
things that were going to happen either
i was going to kill myself kill another
person or end up in jail or some kind of
institution
and that's really kind of what you know
ultimately led me to getting getting
sober and would you say kill yourself do
you mean via alcohol poisoning or a car
accident or via
some deliberate suicide
what do you mean by that i was never
suicidal i didn't have suicidal ideation
but
my life was getting smaller and smaller
and more lonely so if i was able to kind
of maintain that lifestyle over an
extended period of time i'm certain that
i would would have reached a level of
desperation where that would have seemed
like a good idea
why did you choose
law why did you choose to pursue law
it's a very good question you know right
out right out of college i moved to new
york city and got a job as a paralegal
in a in a big law firm in in new york
called skadden arps that's a huge one
and that was you know a situation that
should have told me
immediately that maybe this wasn't the
right path for me
you know
um but i think that that i chose it
not out of some kind of deliberate
idea that it would be
something i would be interested in or
show some proficiency in but more as a
reaction to
social and familial pressures like this
idea of not really knowing what i wanted
to do but hey i can always go to law
school and society will smile upon that
and i can put a nice suit on and have
nice lunches and have interesting
conversations with people and you know
make a good living i mean my
self-inquiry really didn't go any
further than that and there was nothing
about like my
interests that would have indicated that
law was a good path for me but i was so
disconnected from myself that even
asking myself that question at the time
was anathema to
to who i was but i'm a good student and
i actually enjoyed law school i enjoy
the intellectual pursuit and
and all of that but the practice of law
is very different at least in the
corporate law firm context very
different than the law school experience
yes very knowing many people who went to
law school
i can uh
through second-hand stories say that
that seems to universally be
the
the of the perspective that people yeah
but and if you if you love it like if if
that's your thing then more power to you
but i just remember walking the halls of
of you know the various law firms that i
worked at
being confused that there seemed to be
certain people that enjoyed it because i
was just gritting my way through it
thinking i'll just apply these tools
that i learned in the swimming pool
about suffering and
pain tolerance and i just thought
everybody was having that internal
experience
i'm sure many were but there seems to be
some people that seem to enjoy it but i
just know that the more that i kind of
looked around
certainly you know with respect to the
the partners
that it was clear to me that i didn't
really want that life and yet i felt
very stuck in that career path and
unsure about how i could ever get out of
it and do anything else
so we're gonna we're gonna spend just
people listening and also
for for you rich so you don't think that
we're gonna spend too much time in in
these waters we're gonna spend a lot of
time talking about turnarounds
techniques pattern matching all sorts of
things but i do want to spend a little
bit more time
on this chapter or maybe the chapter
shortly after this point in time
what was the straw what were the straws
that broke the camel's back with respect
to
alcohol and seeking help
well there were a couple important
inflection points
one of which was getting two duis
essentially in a row
with ridiculously high blood alcohol
contents
um looking at jail time
my boss finding out at the law firm and
and being on the precipice of getting
fired
that's a whole rabbit hole you know sort
of chaotic disaster that i weathered
another one would was uh
a marriage or i should say like a
wedding that went awry
i got married and that that uh
relationship ended on the honeymoon
which is a whole crazy story story
that is inextricably linked to i mean i
was sober at the time but it's very much
linked to
you know my alcoholism
so there's big events like that but i i
think
you know those situations created such a
deep level of shame inside of me that i
wasn't able to
shake alcohol in the wake of those
experiences because i didn't have the
emotional tools to process them so i
continued to drink for a while i mean
the the the wedding was really you know
the nadir of the whole thing and a
reasonable person would have woken up
and gotten sober at that time but i
needed to medicate myself through
that
emotional [ __ ] storm until one day you
know i i basically woke up and
it was i was hungover but it wasn't like
i had
you know i reaped any kind of chaos the
night before but it's just that moment
of realizing like i've had enough like i
can't live this way anymore it's it's
just so lonely and desperate and it only
leads in one direction
and i think you know
that's what it takes like for anybody
who has experience with addiction
particularly substance addiction
you have this sense like you asked me
earlier on tim like when did i know i
had a problem like i knew i had a
problem very early on in my drinking
career but that's very different from
the willingness to do anything about it
like i harbored this notion that this
was a problem for me but you're also
protecting it because you want to be
able to keep doing it and that's what
that's what leads to you know this sort
of double life where you're hiding your
behavior from other people and deluding
yourself into thinking that they don't
know what's going on but ultimately you
realize like everybody knows what's
going on and
on some level
it's a process of like stripping away
those those layers of denial until you
can really
you know face the objective truth of
what you're doing and that's a very
terrifying thing and and so that's kind
of what was going on inside of me
until you know this day in 1998 where i
was like okay i've had it like i'm i'm
ready to really take this seriously and
do something about it how old were you
roughly then my math is is gonna fail me
at this moment but 1998 yeah i was 31 31
all right
and
because
it struck me as a curveball if you don't
want to get into it that's totally fine
but
in my mind i envisioned this honeymoon
just going down
as a fireball due to
some catastrophe that was alcohol
induced but you said you were sober
yeah are you willing to expand on that
at all
and if not that's fine yeah no
it's so hard to describe this and have
it make sense but essentially what
happened was
i had been drinking quite a bit i got
engaged to this woman
i was living in san francisco at the
time she
was living in palo alto and is from palo
alto
but in the
kind of lead up to this wedding because
we had gotten engaged i had taken a job
in los angeles so we were living in
separate cities and i think during that
interim period when she got distance
between me she realized like maybe this
isn't the guy i want to marry
and i had come clean with her about the
duis and i think that was very scary to
her so even though i had been sober for
a number of months and and told her that
i was committed to this path of sobriety
i think you know in her heart of hearts
she really wanted to get out of this
relationship but she was unable to
muster the strength to break it off
herself and i think that she wanted me
to break it off and so there was so much
energy behind this impending wedding
that was happening that it just kind of
transpired without anybody hitting the
brakes and i was trying to be
conciliatory and say because i knew she
was off and not present and something
was wrong and i would say are you okay
like what's going on how can i make you
feel
comfortable with all of this and it's a
much longer story i go into detail about
it in my book but
essentially you know she
she permitted the wedding to go through
but then
then didn't want to sign the marriage
certificate
that's a red flag
right
cause for pause yeah and you know the
night of the wedding when we went back
to the honeymoon suite that did not go
well i'm surprised that we even went on
the honeymoon but i think in my mind i
was thinking i'm going to try to make
this right and it's all going to work
out like that was its own level of
delusion and while we were on this
honeymoon in a on a caribbean island
it was clear that this relationship had
had no future and ultimately we were
able to have a conversation about it and
she ended up leaving early and at that
moment i was left with myself with no
tools and having been sober for six
months
but unable to really process the the
emotional devastation of having you know
just basically had everybody that i
cared about in the world with like 12
groomsmen in this wedding wedding in
palo alto
you know bear witness to
a marriage that clearly wasn't gonna uh
you know work out and it was really
devastating to me so
i ended up getting drunk on that island
and really struggled to uh get sober
again for quite some time after that
so thank you for sharing that uh
1998
31
i've had enough how do you seek help or
what do you what are your next actions
after that
so prior to that i had been court
ordered to alcoholics anonymous so i had
been to
meetings
but i wasn't doing it because i wanted
to get sober i was doing it because i
was compelled to do it and i think
that's an important distinction
um especially for people who who are
struggling or have people in their lives
that are struggling with a substance
issue you want to help them you want to
intervene
and you can create you know
interventions and things like that to
get people into treatment but ultimately
if that person is resistant to it or
isn't interested in getting sober that's
going to be a very tough hill to climb
so willingness is like crucial
so when i was attending those a meetings
i i lacked that level of willingness it
was more like i just need to get people
off my back so i can go back to living
the way that i want to live and why is
everybody bugging me
but
in the wake of that wedding experience
when my drinking got more and more dire
my parents had reached the level of
their tolerance threshold with me and
basically my dad said listen we love you
but we just can't continue to watch you
destroy yourself like this and we can't
have anything to do with you
but if you're
ready to get sober we're of course hear
from you but until then um
you know we're we're just we're not
available to you however
because they were so terrified of of all
of this they had found an addiction
medicine um
psychiatrist in los angeles they said we
have this guy
you know it might be great if you go and
see him so i started seeing this
addiction medicine specialist
and
he knew you know he just rang my bell
immediately and was like here's the deal
dude you're an alcoholic and you need to
go to treatment until you do that like
nothing's going to change and your
life's going to continue to be terrible
and i would try to negotiate with him
and say well i think i can do it in a.a
so i was kind of in and out of a doing
my own self-experimentation with trying
to get sober
but every time i would crawl back into
his office and i was honest with him and
i said yeah i relapsed again or this
happened
but at some point i made a deal with him
because he was like are you ready to go
to treatment i was like let me try one
more time
and he said okay
and to his credit like i think that's a
really
interesting approach like you have to
back off a little bit and allow people
to have their process it's like
inception like they have to
come into this awareness on their own
you cannot compel somebody to see
themselves as as they really are and of
course i relapsed crawled back into his
office and because i was considered
myself such a man of my word i said well
i made a deal with you so okay now i'll
go to i'll go to treatment and that's
you know i called him after this one
bender and i said i'm ready and he got a
bed for me and i immediately go online
and i'm researching treatment centers
and i'm looking for the like the spa
resort one you know that
that's it that has really nice
accommodations he's like no no no
here's where you're going this place in
oregon i got a bed for you like get on
the plane today and that's basically how
it began
well
what
what do you think
people
tend to miss about this story whether
they hear you telling this story or they
read about it
are there things that
are important that people gloss over
or that
elements of this story whether we've
heard them
today or not
that
stand out to you is particularly
important sort of on the road to
recovery initiating recovery
i think about this type of question a
lot like what is what is what do people
tend to glom onto as the really
important parts what do they tend to
maybe neglect
to their detriment if they're aiming for
recovery themselves
uh does anything come to mind when i say
all that
you're talking like more broadly about
addiction in general not my personal
story i think i'm talking about i'm i'm
weaving into it through your personal
story so it could be your personal story
but it could also be addiction in
a broader sense because part of what
is so interesting to me about you and
your story is you've not only
had the experiences that you've had
but you have no doubt witnessed
many people try to emulate
the turnarounds of various types and
you've seen some people succeed
spectacularly you've seen some people
fail spectacularly and then there's a
whole spectrum in between right so that
i think is
extremely interesting and potentially
instructive right yeah so you could
answer this in in any way you like it
could be from your personal story it
could be from
what you've seen or learned more broadly
speaking about
addiction and recovery
yeah i think there's there's a lot that
i can say about this i mean first with
respect to my personal story
if you google my name there's a lot of
misguided narratives out there that me
adopting a vegan diet is what got me
sober or
that uh you know ultra endurance
training is what got me sober or keeps
me sober and those are all wildly
inaccurate i mean i was sober for almost
10 years before i made these lifestyle
shifts i had a whole chapter in between
where i created a foundation of sobriety
so
sobriety and addiction stand outside of
those things and those other things have
a role in my life but
addiction and recovery are a very
separate thing and that's the way that i
i i kind of think about it and i think
in terms of
addiction and recovery more broadly
i think it's important for people to
understand that
for somebody who is addicted it's not
and who's you know behaving poorly or
all the stuff that you know addicts do
it's not
a referendum on moral character it's
like they're suffering
they're suffering from an illness that
wants to kill them and when they get
sober
we think of drugs and alcohol or
gambling or whatever behavioral
addiction that you know someone might
have
as the problem that has been eradicated
but in truth
the behavior or the substance is the
solution to the problem like
there's a level of psychic pain within a
human being
and they
search out a substance or a behavior
that
gives them some level of solace like the
substance or the behavior is the
solution to the problem because it
allows them to feel okay so that they
can function in the world and it works
for a while if it didn't work people
wouldn't do it but what they miss is
that
it is solving a problem for them of
course it progresses and then things go
sideways
and it's no longer the solution but
that's how it begins and when you remove
those behaviors and substances from
those people
they don't know what to do with
themselves like they're like a live
emotional wire
without any kind of tools for addressing
the underlying problem that has fueled
the addictive behavior for so long
and
you know the process of recovery is
really about
providing tools
some tactical
some strategic
some practical and some very ephemeral
spiritual
that can
be guideposts
in helping people
create new neural pathways and emotional
relationships
with
how they engage with the world and
that's a very slow
non-linear process and that's why
so many addicts and alcoholics you know
have a lot of relapses in their story
and relapses are always treated as
failures but ultimately they're learning
experiences because you're trying to
reorganize your entire life in
accordance with new ways of living that
are very foreign to somebody who has
been engaging in a behavior or
addicted to a substance for so long so
there's a saying in recovery like
your emotional
development gets stunted from the moment
that you begin to use and when you
remove the substance you're left with
that young person uh you know at that
stage of life and you have to treat that
person
with that in mind because they lack the
tools that other people normal people
take for granted and i think the more
that we kind of understand this
it allows us to have a little bit more
compassion for the people that suffer
and
a way to kind of hold them in our hearts
and a little bit
more lightly when they slip up and you
know do the thing because for people
that don't have direct experience with
this
it defies logic like you're like how
could you
do that like after everything that's
happened like you went and did that
thing again like it's so difficult to
understand so i think to the extent that
we can peel back the layers of the onion
and really understand what's fueling
that behavior to begin with
allows us to kind of
you know be more compassionate to those
people
it's really well put and
it it
brings to mind for me something that
a doctor named gabor mate
said
in a conversation i had with him which
was i'm paraphrasing here but he said
don't ask why the addiction asks why the
pain
right and
very much in line with what you just
said
what is what is what is the addiction
being used for
and
makes me imagine and i'm gonna
take a leap here but
i'll go in this direction
i imagine that a lot of the questions
you get about addiction are how did you
stop right how did you stop how did you
stop how did you quit how did you
how did you negate subtract something
but
if that subtraction
leaves a
void of sorts where it leaves an
unaddressed need or
unhealed wound
a few questions related to that if that
resonates with you what do you
what what was it that you
ended up needing to address and what
were some of the tools
or resources or realizations that you
found particularly helpful
for that sort of additive piece
first on on the subject of gabor like i
i had him on my podcast and you know he
he flips the table on you and and
suddenly it becomes a therapy session
which is like amazing you know like it's
like that's exactly what you want right
um
and he was very helpful to me in
addressing that underlying trauma piece
and my resistance to really go there
because i love my parents and i don't
want to blame them and he was helpful in
helping me understand this idea that
like it's not their fault they're good
people
they parented you with the tools that
they had
but that doesn't mean that you didn't
suck just because you weren't
homeless and impoverished or abused in
any particular way it doesn't mean that
you didn't suffer some kind of trauma
that ultimately
is related to you know the behavior that
you pursued later in life
and i think you know to your to your
other point
of tools certainly yeah i mean
i wasn't able to stay sober when i was a
tourist in alcoholics anonymous because
i was sitting in the back just waiting
to get my court card checked that's very
different from engaging with the true
process of recovery and you know i'm a
12-step guy
and you know the the whole
you know alcoholics anonymous thing
is is you know shrouded in anonymity for
a reason so i don't want to get too
specific about that other than to say
that the the steps are the steps for a
reason and it really is this incredible
road map for
unpacking a lot of that underlying pain
and providing you with tools to redress
it in a meaningful practical way
that alleviate that burden and that
shame and allow you to mature into
somebody who can look somebody in the
eye and show up when you say you're
going to show up etc and a big piece in
that is
well there's there's lots of pieces but
one of the crucial pieces is
um doing
an inventory which is the fourth step
where you literally go through your life
and you itemize out all of your
resentments towards people institutions
etc so that you do your resentment
inventory you do a fear inventory where
you itemize everything that you're
scared of and you do a sexual inventory
where you
hold yourself accountable for how your
sexual energy has created you know havoc
in your relationships and i think the
more
comprehensive that inventory the more
clear
the picture is
of how you have conducted your life and
from that themes emerge where you see
these recurrences of like oh when i'm in
this situation i always behave this way
or this type of person always makes me
feel resentful and you can kind of go
behind that and you get a better
understanding of your fundamental
blueprint which is revelatory frankly
but that inventory is only helpful to
the extent that it then allows you to
itemize all of the people to whom you
owe amends because you're carrying
around with that shame this psychic
burden of knowing that you have
wronged people or screwed up situations
or created chaos in other people's lives
and reckoning with that
and then
addressing it by going to these people
and figuring out how to make those
wrongs right
is a huge relief
that is like a pressure valve release on
a lot of that shame
and the more that you engage in this
process you kind of emerge from it
where you can make peace with your past
and it no longer holds all of that power
over you and you can talk about it
freely without it creating all of those
challenging emotions that are so
inextricably related to the errant
behavior itself so that's a huge piece
and that's something that i you know
continue to practice all the time like
it it's something that you return to
constantly
including the tenth step which is
basically do it like a daily 10 step
where you do a daily inventory of how
you've conducted yourself where you
might have gone wrong if you have to
make any kind of like minor amends or
adjustments in your life
and then on top of that
you know meditation is a step in
the 12 steps so daily meditation is
super important as well and there's a
lot more in there but i would say those
are kind of like the fundamental tools
i am so endlessly
fascinated by
12-step programs and
i guess multi-step programs aaa
specifically the story of bill wilson
i find all of it just incredible also
the sort of decentralized nature of aaa
itself
are you aware
and i'll be honest that i i did just a
very cursory search i didn't do a really
dedicated search but are you aware of
any good books or documentaries that dig
into
the history
the
tools of
aaa
are you aware of anything that comes to
mind yeah i'm sure there are those
things that exist i i don't know any
offhand
i know there was that movie that james
woods did a while back where he played
bill wilson but i don't know that i
would recommend that one um i'm sure
there are and there's plenty of kind of
ancillary books around recovery like
there's a book called a new pair of
glasses that you know like sort of
practical applications of the 12 steps
for for people that are that are
suffering
um
i don't know that there's the definitive
history of of alcoholics anonymous or
or the definitive documentary but i
think your your point on
decentralization is so fascinating like
it was blockchain before blockchain you
know like the way that the way that it's
structured is is is truly remarkable
that these guys like you know bill
wilson and dr bob
knew that they had to decentralize it in
order to immunize it from any kind of
external corruption or
you know power dynamic that could um
capsize the whole thing
and the fact that it has not only you
know sustained itself but grown
over the many many years that it's been
around is is truly miraculous and i
think the case study yeah it's amazing
it's really incredible it's a case study
for
how to structure an organization
that's trying to do something good and
not fall prey to you know the the lowest
common denominator of human power
dynamics that tend to
you know fell even the best intentioned
people who are trying to create
something good and it's it's interesting
that it hasn't been replicated to my
knowledge in any other scenarios because
i think there's so much to be learned
about
how it was formed and how it's continued
to to not only survive but thrive
the primary reason i ask is that it just
seems like
this
very obvious jewel in plain sight if
that makes sense and maybe it's the
decentralized nature that makes it
invisible to
a lot of
potentially direct study i don't know
the reasons for it but it's just knowing
a lot of people who are part or have
been part of aaa
and just being introduced
through casual conversation to some of
the
facets of how it works i am
really really fascinated by it and also
for people listening who are thinking
themselves god we're spending a lot of
time talking about addiction and
recovery what does this have to do with
me
i would just take a moment and say
you know when people ask me what do you
do i always kind of flub and don't
really know how to answer it but
i view myself i guess first and foremost
as a student not necessarily expert but
student of
behavioral change and if you look at
alcoholism if you look at other types of
substance use slash abuse if you look at
workaholism if you look at
eating disorders i mean certainly
now being over the last several years
involved in a lot of scientific study
related to different conditions nicotine
addiction
i'd i'd want to say this to glibly but
they're they're they're very overlapping
right so it's studying behavioral change
in the context of
something like addiction
to alcohol
i think transcends that and applies to
many things in the same way that the
training and discipline and pain
tolerance that you cultivated through
swimming
then
was applicable to your studying right
uh
so let's let's talk about the the
physical
turnaround because as you mentioned if i
could just interrupt you can i just
sorry to do that but i think there's one
kind of final important point that i
wanted to make about
addiction i think you're correct like a
lot of people might be listening and
saying well i'm not an alcoholic or a
drug addict and i don't know anyone in
my life that is either how is this
relevant
but as somebody who's been kind of
steeped in this world for for many many
years and
like yourself i've had many guests on my
podcast to discuss this subject matter
i've become increasingly more and more
convinced
that
we
are both very cavalier in how we define
addiction like i'm a chocoholic or i'm a
shopaholic
so we kind of it's a throwaway phrase
but at the same time we're also very
very rigid in how we def we define it in
that you know addiction is like heroin
addiction or opioid addiction and
alcoholism right but i think i'm
becoming convinced that that addiction
lives on this incredibly broad spectrum
and it's a spectrum so broad that almost
anybody can find themselves
somewhere along the line
so on the one hand you have you know the
guy who can't pull the needle out of his
arm
but on the very far other side of the
spectrum you have people who
you know find themselves repeating the
same you know tired self-defeating
narrative about their life and can't get
outside of themselves to see an
objective truth about themselves or the
person who is repeatedly in the same bad
relationship time and time again or the
person who is addicted to you know
whatever it is like video games or
social media scrolling i mean the social
dilemma has really foisted this
conversation onto
mainstream audiences in a way that i
think is is is allowing us to really
think about addiction more broadly
because of the devices that we all have
in our in our pockets
and so
with that
i think it's
helpful to people to understand that
there are tools available to help you
decouple from whatever that thing is
that is holding you hostage or
or creating that obsessive-compulsive
behavior that you can't seem to
transcend
you know despite your best
your best efforts
and the 12 steps yes like they are
crucial and instrumental in helping
people get off drugs and alcohol but
they are very helpful to anybody you
know just to be able to do an inventory
of your life and to see yourself more
objectively and to understand that you
can you know redress these shameful
incidents in your life because we all
have them on some level um i think is
really profound uh and and to the extent
that we are talking about addiction in
this broader context right now i think
is super helpful
because this is the you know this is
an era in which
you know more people have been
become addicted than ever before with
substances and and behaviors and so to
have you know a a conversation about
this i think is super important
yeah
i'm uh i'm really happy we're doing this
and also
the broad applicability of of concepts
from
the 12-step programs uh or aaa in this
case like for instance i'd never heard
this term but i wrote it down lower
companions
yeah i mean it's just such a perfect
phrase
perfect phrasing for what we all kind of
intuit on some level but
having a
simple label for it it makes it much
easier to wield kind of conceptually
right and thinking about about your life
you know we're gonna we're gonna get to
the the physical piece because i have
just selfishly many questions about that
and i'm sure a lot of listeners will be
interested in that and it's related let
me throw out another
mnemonic of sorts but it's it's a very
short
phrase
that i'd love to hear you speak to in
any way that makes sense mood follows
action
i love that one
that was something that my
first sponsor said to me very early on
in sobriety i think i was complaining to
him about some
commitment i had made to sweep the
floors or make coffee or
something along those lines or or
something that had happened to me that
day that i was annoyed with and i
couldn't see my way through
and and he just said you know he just
said mood follows action and what he
meant by that
is
you can't
you can't
think your way
into
into the mood that you seek or the state
of mind that you aspire to inhabit
action is the only thing that can
trigger that change state
and i literally think about this every
single day and it was validated recently
in a podcast that i did with andrew
huberman who i know has been on your
show
where he studied the neurochemistry of
this and realized that
behavior has to come first and thoughts
perceptions emotions follow
from that and when you think about that
in the context of our daily lives like
let's just use running for example like
if you wake up in the morning and you're
supposed to do
a run because you're training for some
race and you don't feel like doing it we
all
resort to that state where we think well
i don't want to do it right now i'll
just wait until i feel like doing it and
then i'll do it then and when we
when we engage
that way we end up never doing it right
like
if you're waiting until you feel like
doing something chances are you're
probably never going to get to it but to
take the action despite how you feel
about it is the thing that catalyzes the
state change and you know in my case or
anybody who's a runner they'll tell you
when they finish the run they're always
glad that they did it they don't
generally regret it and then they feel
better and i think that that example is
applicable to you know all areas of life
so when did you turn
i mean of course in the bio says at age
40
but
why did you
decide to turn the ship around
physically
after getting sober at 31
and emerging from that treatment center
where i lived for a hundred days which
is pretty long time to be in a treatment
center
and being told by the counselors that
you have a very serious case of
alcoholism the kind of case that we
typically only see in lifelong drinkers
like guys in their 60s
it was impressed upon me that i really
needed to get this right or
you know i could i you know i was going
to die like it was just
that point was made to me
very clearly and i was able to hear it
and take it seriously
and so i was super dedicated to
creating this foundation of of sobriety
because my life truly did hang in the
balance and so that became my
main priority
for
many years after that experience so i
returned to los angeles
i was going to multiple meetings a day i
was doing like all the stuff and and
building a new community of friends
because i needed i needed new people you
know i just i couldn't hang out or go to
the places that i had had you know have
been had been going to before
um and with that was also
you know unpacking the shame that i had
about being this person who had all of
this potential and all of these
opportunities that i had squandered and
i felt compelled to repair all of that
and get back to becoming that person
that i was before i started drinking and
i did that with blinders on in my mind
the best way to do that was to
go back to the law firm and you know
work my ass off and become a partner and
you know get all the stuff so that the
world would smile upon me and my parents
would think that i was safe
alcoholics anonymous is spiritual
program and i was developing spiritually
but i had not yet reached the level of
maturity where
i could really look inward and ask
myself those fundamental questions about
what it is that i actually wanted to do
rather than thinking what is society
expecting me to do but what is unique to
me what gets me excited in the morning
what do you think that you're here to
express that is uniquely you like that
just was not part of my
you know mental process in in any way
and so a lot of those addictive
personality traits although i was not
using substances anymore were channeled
into workaholism
and in turn some pretty unhealthy
lifestyle habits so basically 80 hour
weeks
working as a lawyer
and you know hitting the fast food
drive-throughs on the way home and
chinese take out for late nights at work
and
and the like and really despite the fact
that i'd been this swimmer in college
not exercising just not really attending
to or taking care of myself physically
and so over a 10-year period that
accumulates
such that by the time i was 39 i was
about 50 pounds overweight you know
never like an obese person or anything
like that but just kind of like a heavy
guy who looks like you know he works he
works too much in a law firm
and subsisting on junk food and just
feeling progressively worse and worse
lazier
not energized not enthusiastic about my
life
and i think in the in the back of my
awareness was this percolating
existential crisis because i knew that
this career path that i had chosen
was really not for me and i could will
myself into doing it but ultimately it
was not only not making me happy it was
making me more and more
miserable like this square peg and a
round hole kind of thing
but i was too afraid to really look at
that or think about how i could change
that trajectory and there was so i guess
what i'm saying is there was a
confluence of
of poor health
uh on the one side and this you know
spiritual existential crisis that i was
harboring on the other hand
and they essentially collided with each
other shortly before i turned 40 when i
had this specific moment of
you know walking up the flight of stairs
in my bedroom after
a late night at the office
and i had to like stop halfway up a
flight of stairs like i was too winded
to just walk all the way to the top and
i had tightness in my chest and
and you know kind of like i was had that
sweaty pallor on my face from
from a flight of stairs and thinking i'm
like this person who would swam at
stanford and would look in the mirror
and see that person reflected back to me
i realized that i was harboring a whole
other level of of denial that i needed
to look at and it was a scary moment
because heart disease runs in my family
my mother's father had been a champion
swimmer and captain of the university of
michigan swim team in the
late 1920s and early 30s and and you
know a guy who had an american record
and somebody who he's a guy that i'm
named after and in many ways like my
doppelganger but he had died of heart
disease at a young age
and i had this flash where
i realized if i didn't course correct
how i was living that i was
likely headed in his direction
and would meet my demise probably sooner
than he had because there was no
mcdonald's and jack in the box when he
was kicking around
and it was so it was sort of like a
second bottom that was very reminiscent
of the day i decided to get sober like
this very crystallized moment in time
where it's almost like a window of
opportunity
presents itself like a a crack in the
door or a line in the sand
and you have this opportunity to
to harness it
take advantage of it
and
and
take contrary action
or not right and because i was so aware
of how that simple decision of going to
that treatment center had changed my
life so dramatically
that i was being once again visited by
just such a moment i realized that i
needed to take action swiftly because if
i didn't kind of grab onto it
immediately i knew it would just pass
and become ephemera and so that was
really the moment that that catalyzed
kind of everything that that followed
and even you know
the fact that i'm talking to you today
it all tracks back to that very specific
incident
what year are we
talking
more or less do you recall yeah this
would have been let's see
2000
i was just about to turn 40 so
2006.
okay
did this coincide
with
something i've
read you describe as complete financial
dismantlement which sounds brutal
doesn't sound pleasant
was that around the same time before or
coinciding that started a little bit
later it was sort of precipitated by the
crash in 2008 and it continued through
uh
years after publishing finding ultra
like it was a very extended period of
time
of of being challenged to even put food
on the table
you know we i've all these cheat sheets
in front of me of course and you know
one of the one of the questions i
like to ask as you well know you know
what what is the best or most worthwhile
investment you've ever made could be
time money energy etc and
you know i give various examples of this
but it could be warren buffett talking
about his best investment being
investing in dale carnegie's speaking
classes or anything at all and you have
you have a couple here
three
decision to train for 2008 ultraman
stepping back from the law to right
finding ultra
and then starting your podcast
so we could focus on the first one but i
want to if it's okay with you and feel
free to redirect
look at the second one stepping back
from the law to right finding ultra when
was that that you stepped back to do
that
i started writing it in
i think
late 2010 or early 2011. okay so the
reason the reason i ask
there seem to be these inflection points
and right inflection could go
multiple directions not only up but
there seemed to be
certain decisions that in retrospect
just
really make a lot of difference in
direction
how did you decide to step back from the
law to write this book given
the complete financial dismantlement and
all of these various things going on
at the time was it and was it an easy or
hard decision
um
i think it was a little bit of both uh
at that time i had already been
scaling back on my law practice i was
balancing training for these crazy races
which we can talk about and becoming
less and less interested in being a
lawyer and at that time i was
self-employed as a lawyer i i had made
the step of getting out of the big
corporate
law firm hustle and had a couple
different incarnations of
of my practice being solo being with a
couple partners etc
so i had flexibility over how i was
allocating my time and you know the four
hour
work week was actually really helpful
at that time in helping me wrap my head
around how i could
straddle these both worlds and and still
get things done so the truth is i had
already begun to take my foot off the
gas a little bit on on the law practice
but the opportunity to write this book
was such a remarkable occurrence that i
could have never
predicted happening in in my life and i
just felt so grateful to even have the
opportunity that was an inbound email or
outreach of some type it's actually a
really interesting story so what
happened was
i had been doing these races and getting
some notoriety for it and some press
and an article came out in the stanford
alumni magazine and it had mentioned
what i was doing and it it had also
mentioned that that i had had this
struggle with with alcoholism and have
been sober for a while
and
somebody who i only knew very
tangentially
sent me an email and said hey i read
that article
i'm recently out of a treatment center
like he was an alumni i'm recently out
of treatment center and i'm the ceo of
this company my board doesn't know like
i need somebody to talk to like can we
just talk and so i struck up a phone
relationship with this person and was
just trying to help him and you know
guide him to make good decisions about
how to conduct himself in early sobriety
and at some point he said hey i know
this
book agent like you have such an amazing
story like let me introduce you to this
person and at that time i hadn't thought
of writing a book it wasn't on my list
of things that
i was thinking of doing
and
that conversation with that book agent
basically made me feel comfortable
giving it a stab
and it was kind of a charmed thing where
i wrote a proposal i worked really hard
on it because i recognized the unique
and amazing opportunity it presented
and that led to
getting a book deal really quickly and
so suddenly my life
priorities changed because i was able to
recognize that this could be a lever
that would propel me into an entirely
new
universe of opportunities and
trajectories with my career so
prioritizing the writing of that book
was like the most important professional
commitment that you know i made at that
time and and and really created the
foundation for
me me being able to do kind of all the
things that i do now
you do quite a few things and uh quite
well i will add uh
you're welcome so you know we you i
should say can i can i just say like
really quickly sorry to interrupt you
but like
you have no idea how much that means to
me tim like it really is meaningful that
you said that because i look to you and
the example that you've set and all the
things that you
have done in the world in such a
remarkable fashion and you know i aspire
to
your level of of impact and influence
and i just also so i wanted to thank you
for that and thank you also for
being a support to me like when the book
came out you let me do a guest blog post
for your site i think i pestered you and
you know
until you finally relented but that was
extremely helpful to me at the time and
i i r you have no idea how much i
appreciate that oh thank you rich well
it was my it was my pleasure and
i i will say that
a compelling story is a compelling story
so i
really appreciate the kind words and
you're doing a hell of a job man i mean
i
i really admire the work that you're
doing in the world and
uh it's it's fun for me to be sitting
here asking you four very thinly failed
advice i've been very indirect so far
but
but thank you for that very welcome i
figure
just as a way of and we can go anywhere
we want to go of course but we're
recording this around the turn of the
new year
i am in the next year going to turn 45
and
i've realized just in the last few years
really that
because i used to
not at your level with within this kind
of dynastic
famed
team at stanford for swimming which we
might come back to at some point
but
had competed in as an athlete and when i
competed i found it very easy to
motivate
for a lot of reasons right i mean
uh but there's a lot of positive and
negative reinforcement involved when you
compete
and then in the last let's just call it
four or five years
have continued to train but in a pretty
lackadaisical
ad hoc way right lots of travel going to
gyms kind of figuring out what i'm going
to do when i get to the gym no real
programming to speak of and what i've
realized in the last few years is
what i was able to pull off for
let's just say
10 years of
decent
kind of mediocre to high mediocre
training is just not going to cut it
moving forward
metabolically or otherwise
and i've trained before
and having competed before and i have
found
a lot of shame around
and and judgment around having let it
slip if that makes any sense
and
nonetheless i have
have really decided all right 2022 this
is this is the year
that i want to make some significant
changes
given the book given your podcast you
have no doubt observed many people try
to emulate what you've done to differing
degrees of success
what advice would you give to someone in
my shoes it could be advice to me but
someone who is considering this
sort of doing a reboot
given the sort of the sample set that
you've observed over time or just from
your direct experience
well i mean i guess the first thing i
would ask you tim is like why like why
do you
like what is going on what's beneath the
kind of surface level
aspect of this that you just shared like
what is it that your you feel is
lacking that would be fulfilled by you
pursuing some kind of fitness goal is it
just like oh i'm starting to feel lazy
or i've slipped off or i don't feel the
way that i'd like to feel right now or
like i always like to ask that first
because people are very casual and
cavalier about saying i want to do this
goal like i want to do this race or
whatever and i'm always like why like
why is that important why is that
important to you right so that would be
the first thing i would ask you
yeah i have answers so the first
i think overarching answer is mood
follows action right so i know that when
i am
training consistently with a purpose
of some type not just going to yoga a
few times a week i can do that i can
lift weights two or three times a week
but
training with a purpose i find just
leads me to a
a
better
mental psycho-emotional state more often
than not it is the most reliable
intervention so to speak
so that would be part one part two
and
we'll we'll see where this goes but i
really really miss
the
camaraderie of being on
a team or striving towards a similar
goal
probably it doesn't have to i've never
had that experience in a co-ed capacity
so it doesn't necessarily have to be all
men but that
experience
which i found challenging to replicate
outside of sports would be another
reason
and you know i stopped doing judo and
jiu jitsu and so on quite a while ago
just because of the the number of
injuries
i'm okay with intermittent injuries they
just take a lot longer to heal from now
than they did when i was
16 to 22. or whatever
so
those those would be top of the list and
i think that
related to the first answer this like
mood follows action i think that self
and we could probably pick this apart
i'm sure but like self-image also
follows action like i just have i feel
better about myself when i am
training
with some degree of
focus and
a goal of some type you know especially
if it's time bound i just do very well
with that
and i haven't you know over coveted and
everything else not to make excuses but
i i have i have been very
bad at doing that and still like i'm
training a couple times a week but i've
realized
i'm barely skating by kind of like look
fit with clothing on fit which is
not not enough for me at this point i
enjoy i should also say i just i really
i do enjoy
pushing myself
physically right maybe not to the point
like when i was much younger i would
like go for training runs for or sprint
workouts for wrestling or whatever and i
would run until like the blood vessels
would burst in corners of my eyes like i
don't need to do that anymore i think
that's kind of kind of silly for me at
this point but that's that's a
long-winded
answer
to your question no that was a that's a
great answer and and just knowing enough
about you to know how important like
structure is to you like setting really
measurable
tangible goals and benchmarks like
that's kind of how you operate
and that's the easy part for you but i
think the harder part is figuring out
what vayne you know like what what is
the character of the actual pursuit
right and i would start with curiosity
like what is it that is something you're
interested in learning or exploring that
might be something new that sits a
little bit outside of your comfort zone
but is intriguing enough for you to want
to explore it like it's easy to say well
you should do this race or you should
try this or you should you know join a
team but i think curiosity is really you
know the most important piece like
because if you're not interested in it
if you're not if it's not something
that's going to get you excited and have
some ability to retain your attention
and enthusiasm chances are like you're
gonna get bored or you're you're just
gonna you're gonna drop off so yeah
starting with that i think is important
because i could tell you you should do
this but only you know
what that might look like but i would
suggest that
spending time with that curiosity and
then figuring out how you can
pursue that learning curve in a in a
challenging fitness context that also
involves community or team building on
some level because that's the other
piece that you feel like you're missing
and i i get that like i i miss that too
you know and i do most of my training
alone and when i do group runs i'm like
i should do this more like this is so
fun and yet i don't do it so i relate to
that deeply but i think those would be
good starting places like things that
come to mind for me is some kind of
adventure race you know or something
where it involves other people and lots
of different types of skill sets that
come into play that
is kind of scary but also
experiential and potentially very fun
yeah or orienteering something like that
and i should also say that the the team
or
the team piece is also it could be a
partner piece
and i think fundamentally for me what
that is is an accountability piece
right
because
and i'm sure you experience this quite a
bit too it's like it's not the
it's not the
bad i the pursuit of bad ideas i mean it
could be but it's it's not the the
pursuit of bad ideas or worthless
tasks that will drown you it's it's like
saying yes to too many
cool-ish things
not a handful or one truly great thing
does that make sense right so this is
like my major malfunction these days
like
like i am dying death by a thousand cuts
these days because of like cool stuff
that i want to do and say yes to to you
know too frequently
yeah so you can just drown in that stuff
and if i don't have
an anchor you need an anchor i need an
anchor there needs to be a consequence
to me being like ah i'm doing this
[ __ ] on my laptop at 4pm and i'm
going to push off this workout that's
scheduled for 4 30. i want
there to be a consequence to that and
you know there are a lot of ways to set
up stakes and consequences but a very
easy way to do it is just train with
somebody which is part of the reason why
one of the
most consistent forms of exercise i've
been able to get in the last say
six months is rock climbing because i'm
going with a belay partner and if they
show up and i'm not there it's just
it's a real dick move
yeah so adventure racing i was thinking
orienteering possibly although that that
you know i say that really knowing very
little
about it are there any other
characteristics that you've been able to
spot
amongst just patterns of people making
attempts at this over and over again
yeah i mean the other thing i would
point out is
the tendency to indulge in a little bit
of analysis paralysis
you know like you could spend the next
year trying to figure out what mountain
it is that you want to climb or how
you're going to get there and i have a
sense that you know maybe this might be
a thing for you and i think there's a
lot of value in not overthinking things
and just saying this is something that's
interesting to me i'm just going to
decide right now i'm going to do this
thing and it's like six months from now
and it's in the calendar and i have no
idea how i'm going to get there but it's
there you know and i think
that that compulsion to want to know all
the answers and how it's going to play
out and all the steps you're going to
need to take to get there
can
prevent us from moving forward in our
lives and i think these situations in my
experience are rigged such that you're
not supposed to know all of those
answers because you're rewarded for
actually
getting into action like it's tangential
to mood follows action like action
will
lead you
like the bricks get laid you know only
two steps in front of you and you're not
allowed to see the whole thing right
like use iron man for example or
triathlon like what bike should i get
well you can go around that
merry-go-round forever but ultimately
the best bike is the one that's sitting
gathering dust in your garage just do go
do a race with that and you'll figure
out all that stuff as you go and you
know it's it becomes the more you do it
the more emotionally engaged you get
with it and then it these things tend to
you know develop a life of their own
all right i i have
a very specific question for you came up
before we started recording
and i thought you know this is
something i know very little about so
you can you can safely assume that i can
be a very effective stand-in for anyone
in the audience who doesn't know what
this is zone 2 training
could you
share your thoughts
recommendations cautionary tales
anything related to zone 2 training
perhaps beginning with a definition
because this is something that
as you know dr peter tia has has spoken
quite widely about
what is zone 2 training
well first of all like your conversation
with peter on the subject matter and
then peter i know has done like amas
where he's
dove very deeply into this topic are
fantastic listens and everybody should
check that out if they're interested in
the subject matter because my version of
explaining this will be a very lay
person's experiential version of it
compared to peter's very scientific and
eloquent you know yeah exactly
but yeah i'm a huge
huge proponent of zone two training and
i believe that
my
fidelity and adoration of the zone two
philosophy is a cornerstone in how i was
able to be successful in ultra-endurance
triathlon in my mid-40s so zone 2
basically
is a
gauge of
energy output
in aerobic exercise
that essentially is the state in which
you are exerting yourself out of at
essentially a conversational level you
are in your aerobic zone where your body
can make use of one of two sources of
energy glucose or fat
and it is the level of exertion that
lives and breathes just beneath where
you cross a certain threshold and go
into a more anaerobic state which is
dependent more or exclusively on
glycogen stores for energy in endurance
training zone 2 i think is absolutely
crucial for success because it is the
best way
or the methodology that you leverage to
create efficiency which is something
that peter has talked about so
most people
when they go out for a run let's say
they go
on a run a 45 minute run like three or
four times a week or something like that
most people
will go out and they will exert
themselves so that they feel like they
had a vigorous run like they'll run as
fast as they can
to you know for that period of time so
that when they're finished they feel
like oh i got something out of that
zone two is a level of output that is
quite a bit beneath that level of
exertion because when you're doing that
kind of mindlessly like i'm just going
out for a vigorous run
most typically you are in what is called
the gray zone
you're going too hard and too fast to
really develop that aerobic capacity and
engine and efficiency but you're not
going hard enough to develop
speed and the anaerobic kind of capacity
that you're looking for for those really
fast shorter
bursts
and in that gray zone which is where
most average people live and breathe you
can get to a certain point but you will
very quickly plateau and really never
go beyond that
zone two is a is a certain kind of
discipline because it's asking you to
hold back
zone two is the level of output where
like basically you can get up and do it
every day and quite often you complete
the workout and you feel like you didn't
do anything and you you have this
impulse to want to go faster so you have
to hold back from doing that
but essentially what it does is it as
peter talks about develop helps you
develop
a greater mitochondrial density in your
muscles and in ultra endurance this is
absolutely crucial because there's
nothing about ultra endurance that is
fast it has nothing to do with threshold
power or speed or any of that it's
truly the ability to
efficiently persist so
the prize doesn't go to the fastest guy
it goes to the person who slows down the
least and when you
kind of live in this zone two place
where you're training you know for long
periods of time
developing this capacity
what you're doing is you're building
this foundation of endurance from the
ground up and the way that you kind of
calculate your zone i mean peter talks
about this i go in for proper lactate
testing i'm on a bike and i get my
finger pricked as the watts go up and
you get this heart rate zone in this
watt zone
wherein
you understand like this is the level of
exertion required to like be right in
the sweet spot of all of this
when i began training for these races
my zone two
like case uh when i was running was like
10 minutes a mile or 10 30 or something
like that but by
rigorously adhering to this without
doing any interval training or any tempo
work
over a two year period i got to the
point where i could run seven minute
miles at the same heart rate
so the same amount of energy output but
that level of increase in speed not by
doing any speed work but by literally
creating efficiencies and developing
that mitochondrial density and
ultimately what you're also doing is
training the body to metabolize fat for
fuel which is your you know all-day
source of energy like you literally will
never run out of it um so in my
experience
training the body to metabolize fat for
fuel has really been it's an n of one an
experiential
experience that i've had but it's really
much more about
how you're training than what it is that
you're eating or when you're eating it
like i've just found this training to be
the best way to get into that place of
of the body learning how to you know
metabolize fuel in that way so that you
can literally continue to go for as long
as you want
and there are and certainly i'll link in
the show notes to the conversations with
peter etia that that go uh
probably deeper than that so i think
it's technically it's great it's great
it does get technical but peter knows
his stuff i'll i'll provide some links
to that for people who want to to dig in
i would you chopped it out and then put
it at the end and i went immediately to
the end to like listen to all
right so for people who haven't heard
this episode basically the first maybe
was the first question and we launched
into the cellular metabolism involved
with zone 2 training and
mitochondrial density i thought you know
maybe that 20-minute
appendix should be put at the end as an
appendix
just so that we can get people in the
door right so we're not having people do
calculus on their way into the club
maybe on the way out
but
it is a great section so we'll we'll
link to that uh in the show notes at 10.
blog podcast question for you and this
may be a dead end but i'm just curious
have you
explored using
ketone
meters as you have adapted and increased
your mitochondrial density through zone
2 training and the reason i'm asking is
i'm wondering if you've noticed for
instance because this is something i
track but without the zone 2 training
in the case of say a two or three day
fast
how quickly my body will go to
will shift over to say you know 0.7
millimolars or something like that get
to the point where i feel like i am in
ketosis just subjectively through
cognitive sharpness you know mental
acuity generally have you played around
with that at all or seen a faster
switchover no i've never i haven't i
haven't yeah yeah i don't have any
experience with that would make sense
though that would make a lot of sense
how often
how frequently is it necessary to do
zone 2 training i'm sure it's highly
individual but just painting with a
broad brush to begin to accrue some of
the benefits that we're talking about i
think peter answered this question and i
i believe he gave a window of something
like three months or something like
three to six months um i would say that
this is not like the way to
hack yourself to success because it
requires a significant uh investment in
time like you you have to play the long
game to really reap the the huge
benefits of this type of training it's
not an overnight kind of thing i started
to realize gains maybe around six months
into it but i didn't really
garner the full you know buffet of
of what it was availing me for a lot it
took two years like basically is what
i'm saying like the longer you do it the
more efficient you become
and then the longer you can go
the further you can sustain a certain
level of effort and these adaptations
are like not overnight but i think it's
like when you're looking at like it's
not like what are you gonna do this year
but like three years if you're on like a
three-year plan i think really doubling
down on this philosophy
there's just there's so much benefit to
it
but it depends on what your goal is too
what is my goal i'm in the process of
figuring that out
i have to i have to dig into that
curiosity we were talking about earlier
and uh certainly part of that will be
know thyself still working on that
aren't we all i think i've been in the
gray zone side note for like two years
which is probably
has some explanatory power so there are
three things at least three things but
three things i would love to hear you
speak to and i'll let you you mentioned
buffet so i'll throw out three
and then you can pick whichever one you
want to tackle first so
one is sleeping in a tent
two is taking a full month off the grid
every year
and then
number
three is your daily architecture
so not committing to certain things or
focusing on certain things
up to 12 noon
uh which which one of those would you
like to dig into i mean we could go any
direction you want i mean we could start
with the tent let's start with the tent
yeah
so uh i've been sleeping
outside in a tent for a couple years at
this point i think a little over two
years
and i absolutely love it
it's really been beneficial to my sleep
and it's something that started
from
a frustration
over
my increasing inability to get
restful slumber
and the impetus like kind of original
impetus was
my wife
likes the bedroom warm i like the
bedroom cold i'm sure a lot of people
can relate to this
relationship dynamic and no matter how
much we would try to compromise to
you know
make it good for both of us
julie would always be bundled up under a
ton of covers and i'm sleeping on top of
the covers like sweating and then
neither of us sleeps and we get up and
and we're not happy
we have a flat we've been in my house i
have a flat roof on my house and one
summer evening
we did a sleepover on the roof with the
kids and we have a flat wall where we
would project movies and we're like
eating popcorn and we all just kind of
slept on the roof that night
and in sleeping bags and i woke up the
next day just feeling amazing like from
the outdoor air and the cool like desert
air of los angeles and i was like i
can't remember the last time i slept so
well so i told julie i was like i'm just
going to sleep on the roof again tonight
and it really began from there and i
just fell in love with being out there's
something about being outdoors that just
agrees with me in the kind of cool
evening air
but i would wake up covered in like like
condensation like completely wet so i
was like all right i got to get a tent
so then i got a tent the tent was on the
roof then it got windy i moved the tent
to the ground but i've really just
enjoyed it and as i get older like i'm
so protective of my sleep and it's so
important to me
that i get those eight hours because i
know what it feels like not to get them
and i it still eludes me quite often
like i i really struggle with this but
it's been a huge benefit in
the quality of my sleep and
i enjoy it
people always ask like well you know
they think i'm having like some kind of
fight with my wife or something like
that like
we have our quality time i promise you
like everything is fine in my marriage
we've been together for a very long time
it's all good um
and i also think it's been a cool
kind of stoic practice because i i live
in a really nice house and i have nice
things
but i actually prefer to sleep in the
tent and there's something about that
where
it gives me comfort like if everything
went terribly wrong and i lost
everything like i know that i'm
happy sleeping in a tent and
i don't really need that much ultimately
and that that's been really kind of
nice in
cultivating a little bit of a minimalist
sensibility about how i live
so you decided being blown off the roof
while you're sleeping is probably not a
good idea i second that
do you have mountain lions around those
parts
we do and i i
i go running in all the trails all
around you know where i live in the
santa monica mountains i know they're
there i've never seen one but they're
definitely there where our property is
fenced so i feel
okay
but yeah i mean for they're they're
there they're real but
yeah we'll see
i remember this experience in northern
california up by napa i went on this
hiking
trip and everybody at the same time got
the feeling that they were being watched
and i was like yeah we should probably
pay attention to that
mountain lions everywhere
uh what yeah forgive me but my a i want
to know b my my listeners will be
annoyed if i don't ask
so you you you did a lot of trial and
error with tent and setup and everything
else what does your gear look like
currently after two years of trying it
out yeah well i'm actually at a at a
turning point with all of this i've been
sleeping in
like a north face tent uh that i've had
for a while but the these tents tend to
only last like maybe
four or five months at most because the
sun just beats them up and then they
turn into like tissue paper so i'm
constantly getting new tents and finally
i was like this is ridiculous
so i just bought like a proper
canvas like glamping tent and we haven't
constructed it yet i'm having a deck
build i'm gonna make it like kind of
like a cool
outdoor structure so that's the next
chapter in all this but for the last two
years it's been a series of you know
basically you know small tents in the
backyard i have a mattress in there so
i'm not sleeping on the ground and tons
of blankets which is part of the appeal
like there was frost when i woke up this
morning it was great i slept fantastic
last night but a key thing that i have
been using for a couple years is gravity
blanket which i absolutely love i don't
know if you've had any experience yeah i
have one upstairs so what why
what is the gravity blanket and why do
you find it helpful
gravity blanket is a a weighted blanket
there's different types of them but
essentially they're quilted with
like uh i don't know sand in them or
different types of of heavy materials so
and they come in different weights so i
think mine is like a 25 pound blanket so
imagine
that experience of being at the dentist
and you're getting an x-ray and they put
that like lead mat on your chest
and think is that a pleasant experience
for you or an unpleasant experience for
you and when i think about that
i kind of like it like there's something
about it swaddling clothes yeah it's
like i'm being protected you know it's
like telling my
my
sympathetic nervous system that i'm safe
and i believe i could be wrong but i
believe that that was the original
use case for the gravity blanket to
treat people with autism who have
trouble calming down and it had this
impact of like soothing them and that's
certainly you know been my experience
using it and i i love it you use it at
night yeah you put that on top of your
blankets
all right so tent
check uh any other modifications that
you've made to your tenting experience
that come to mind uh
no i mean i wear an i have an eye mask
um but just type of eye mask
of course the tim ferriss i forgot what
i got i gotta ask
the mindfold i like the mind fault oh
mindfuls are great yeah yeah
all right
check all right now
thank you for indulging that
inquiring minds want to know of course
and you know for for people who uh
want
another example of this type of stoke
practice different type of time frame
but kevin kelly who's been on the
podcast at least two times arguably the
world's most interesting man
he will
sleep in his living room in a sleeping
bag
kind of surviving on as i as i recall
uh instant oatmeal and instant coffee
for
maybe like a a week a year
two weeks a year just as a little
reminder that all is well everything's
fine
but i like the idea of sleep sleeping
outside a lot more personally it's a
daily architecture or weekly
architecture just schedule wise
seems like you rarely schedule certain
types of things before noon your time
could you speak to
speak to that and perhaps just tell the
genesis story like how and when did you
begin doing that because that's
contraindicated if you're doing 80 hour
weeks
right so there's a there was a
transition yeah of course that didn't
really become a possibility until i was
i was self-employed and i think i
started practicing it
originally when i was writing finding
ultra because i needed i needed quiet
hours before work began to just be
focused on that important thing
and i've just built upon it from there
so essentially i'm early to bed early to
rise i go to bed like around nine
and i generally get up around
sort of five five between five and six
and the early hours are are really
protected as my own time so
morning meditation
journaling
writing
creative projects no meetings no phone
calls like certainly like we're doing
this podcast this morning so i'll make
exceptions like we're doing this in the
morning but as a general rule i try not
to commit to anything outside of those
practices for that initial phase of the
day and so after i finish those
practices then i i do my training in the
morning
and i try to get that done before i go
into the work day
how
frequently would you say you succeed
if you and i'm not to ever expect it to
be 100 i'm just curious
what you would say it looks like and
when you get something because we were
talking about the death by a thousand
cuts earlier when you get really
tempting stuff
what do you do right like sometimes you
make exceptions but if you if you made
all the exceptions then the schedule
wouldn't work right because i'm sure you
have people right stuff earlier in the
day so
what's your what would you say your hit
rate is and
how do you contend with the
the temptations
i would say outside of situations where
i'm traveling my hit rate's about 85
so that's high i'm pretty good yeah and
also
the people that i generally work with
like all know this now so it's less
often that i'm asked to do things during
those hours because like
because they know
and i've gotten much better at just just
not agreeing to do stuff
uh conference calls zoom calls and stuff
like that during that period of time but
if somebody's in you know the uk or in a
you know a very a radically different
time zone like there's situations where
it's like okay am i going to be the huge
pain in the ass or am i going to just
make an exception
you know so make them do the zoom call
at 11 pm yeah yeah like
i'm too much of a people pleaser for
that and that's the war that i'm always
waging like the healthy boundary versus
like the desire to be liked is is like
the battleground in my head and so
i'm pretty good about that the death by
a thousand cuts shows up in in other
areas of my life particularly like
regarding stuff that
isn't due or isn't going to happen for a
long period of time like if it's far
enough out on the calendar i'll pretty
much agree to anything
and you know and then and then that day
arrives and you're like what am i doing
i'm never doing this again and then the
following week you're you know reaping
the same thing so
i you know that's
that's like my mount everest right now
and listen these are these are problems
of of abundance they're the result of of
you know working very hard to create
something that is interesting to people
and so you get offered cool stuff and i
want to take advantage of all the cool
stuff like i know what it's like to
not have people interested in having me
involved in cool stuff
but at what cost right and yeah and it's
really hard to do that it's like do you
want to go do this amazing thing you're
like 100 i do but
what are you really trying to accomplish
where is your focus you know vested
and
calibrating those opportunities against
the things that are most important in
your life and you know i have four kids
like i have you know i have other
responsibilities outside of my
professional responsibilities that are
important to me so
i'm not always great at making those
decisions but i think i'd like to think
that i'm getting a little bit better
well 85 percent hit rate's really good
that's just for the pre
pre noon thing that's not for
like fielding all incoming you know
stuff still that's a good protected zone
that's a good protected zone you know i
i've
and no surprise to anyone just
fascinated by how people think about
scheduling and time
i know that you've been
doing some workouts with laird hamilton
and gaby reese's place in the pool
xpt and all that which is
side note on sleep i have probably never
slept better than after a really long
workout with weights in the pool my god
it's incredible
it's just amazing and they have such
unique lives and the way that they
live their lives
fiercely independently
and i they came to mind also because i
was thinking about rick rubin the
legendary music producer has been on
this podcast
who also i'm not sure where he is now
but
often spends time with them and has his
little corner
in the pool where he does his workout
but rick
as far as i can tell
basically doesn't schedule
like 99 of life is unscheduled it's kind
of like yeah like ping me and if it
works it'll work and i really admire his
ability to do that
i haven't been able to ace that at this
point hence the questions about all of
this
a month off the grid every year is this
uh let's let's go to the genesis story
for this
and
how and why
this is a priority
so you mentioned earlier on this this
extended period of financial
dismantlement that that we endured as a
family and
and it was a very painful extended
period of time where
i really struggled to figure out how to
provide for my family
in a meaningful way and
it's now all solved and everything's
great but i think there was a
significant amount of ptsd that i
experienced from that because it was
very emasculating and scary for me
yeah and now that everything you know
once things started you know functioning
properly and
and and working
a lot of my workaholism tendencies kind
of
came to the forefront
and i became
so focused on building this thing and
protecting it and making sure that it
was
providing for my family that
i started to kind of overlook the
principles that put me in the position
to create it in the first place like the
adage of like all this wellness is
making me sick like i was so
you know like i was just working my ass
off right and as you know doing this
show and doing other things in your life
like it's a lot more work than people
think like it's a it's a grind and you
can lose yourself in it and a couple
years ago i i started tiptoeing up
to burnout and instead of being excited
to have conversations with my guests i
was i wouldn't say i was dreading it but
i was i was moving in that direction and
that's not a relationship that i wanted
to have with this
thing that you and i both do that we
obviously really care about
it it should be a joyful experience and
you know i hadn't taken a single
vacation in like five years like no
break it was insane so
you know it was i was i was due for it
and so i ended up taking a month off and
i went to australia and it was
incredibly nourishing and i was able to
come back from that experience with a
renewed and refreshed
perspective and and relationship with
with what i do and i just decided that
this was going to be an annual thing so
i'm getting ready to do i'm taking
january off this year and i'm really
looking forward to it like i i i need it
and i think it's
you know it's important to
understand in a performance context that
you have to periodize your life just
like you would periodize your training
like you need those
fallow periods to
recharge the battery and you have to
live your life if you're going to have
anything worthy to say about the human
experience like if you're just
constantly engaging in your profession
and focused on
you know what it is that you do and
you're missing out on the other
experiences and the richness of life
then you're not really going to be
carrying a meaningful resonance or
vibration that's going to be helpful to
other people
let's go to pre-australia for a moment
because
no no vacation in five years and then i
took a month off and it was great i feel
like we're skipping a few steps
what did the preparation
slash self-talk logistics anything look
like leading up to australia and if you
want to mention this first we can
mention this part first which is what
did what did off really mean
off didn't mean like completely like
like leave the phone at home you know i
would i i wish i could tell you that
that's what i did i didn't do that
that is an ambition for this
experience though uh which is terrifying
that i'm excited about
so what are you asking specifically like
the the yeah what type of what type of
preparation is required now if
if this current example meaning january
coming up is
is a better case study to take a look at
i'm just wondering what the preparation
looks like right so you have all of
these various
plates that you're spinning of different
types
and i i literally just got back a few
days ago from from uh about three weeks
off the grid so i'm fresh oh wow having
just returned where i was in antarctica
so i literally oh wow
zero cell or wi-fi signal which was
great because the
possibility of backsliding is basically
removed entirely unless you want to like
sit in a tent by yourself with a
satellite phone and try to make that
work which some people did
but i did not so i'm wondering
what
prep is going into
taking a month off
i'm much more interested in your
experience in antarctica but yeah well
you can talk about it i mean that's
amazing like what were you why did you
decide to go there and what was that
about
i have a friend uh matt mullenweg who
very close friend he's been on the
podcast once or twice he runs a company
this makes it all the more impressive so
he runs a company called automatic
m-a-t-d-i-c which has something like 2
000 employees at the moment
he had gone to antarctica i want to say
i might be getting the numbers off but
five or six years ago
and had heard that a trip
was being planned which would
put
a small group in antarctica
for the totality the solar eclipse at
the empire penguin colony which had
never been observed before
in this year to end of 2021 and that was
the
purpose of this trip he grabbed a number
of seats
made a reservation for a handful of
seats five or six seats
and then invited me some time ago and
asked me if i wanted to go and i said
yeah i absolutely want to go i mean when
am i next going to have such an invite
and
ended up
landing
in chile spending a decent amount of
time in chile they're very very very
strict with kovid so you're getting
daily covet tests you're being tr you
install an app and you're legally
required to identify your location and
answer surveys
every day you carry a mobility pass
which is a qr code to go into any
establishment
that then interfaces with the database
to indicate whether you are green or red
so very very involved which it has to be
because if if you have an outbreak in
antarctica the whole operation is done
right right
and then off we went but i i it had been
a while been a couple of years
since uh well certainly since covid
hit that i had spent
multiple weeks completely off the grid
which i i try to spend at least two to
three weeks per year 100 off the grid
meaning
if there's an emergency someone can
contact someone who contacts someone who
can find a way to reach me but there's
really
no contact with the outside world
otherwise
and so in my case
i'd love these experiments because and
hence my interest in what you're up to
also because you're forced to look at
all of your systems right like if you're
gone for a week
you can come back and fire fight you can
kind of allow things to
go towards entropy and balls to get
dropped and then
fix it when you get back but
with the with the amount that is going
on i imagine in your life certainly in
my life if you try to do that with three
or four weeks it's just going to be a
catastrophe so you have to set up
systems and policies and update things
and take a really close look at like
okay well how are
wires being approved how are these
following things being handled oh
they're being handled in this really
labor-intensive ad hoc one-off way let's
make a policy for that what should the
policy be
and
uh all of those or many of those things
outlive
the vacation right which so that's an
additional argument in addition to the
periodizing of
life right the fact that you are a
biological system that does not have
infinite amounts of neurotransmitters
and cortisol and so like you really it's
a good idea
to kind of phase in and phase out
you know the other argument for me and
there are many others of course i mean
enjoying your goddamn vacation would be
a great one too but in the case of
someone who's self-employed or maybe
even if you are employed you you develop
and refine systems that then
have
durability and persist once you get back
so so i'm just getting back in the
saddle after multiple weeks literally i
have only been in the u.s for a handful
of days wow what an amazing experience
yeah so i'm on the other side
yeah that's cool yeah i think
now i get where you're coming from i
mean
it's certainly been a situation of of
putting systems in place and stress
testing them i mean i have this amazing
team right now when i went to australia
the team looked a little bit different
it wasn't as mature as it is at this
point but now i've i've really invested
a lot of time and energy in creating
structure which was not easy for me as a
sort of control freak who wants to do
everything and be the bottleneck in
every decision and every problem like
i've lived in that
that was big a big part of what was
leading me towards this burnout was my
refusal to kind of loosen the reins and
empower people around me and that's been
you know an education
that i'm happy to say i'm now very much
you know much more on the other side of
which feels really liberating
and having systems in place so that i
can go away
and i've got you know these people here
who have their eyes on the prize and can
take care of a lot of that stuff but it
took many years to get to this place and
i had to learn a lot of rocky
you know lessons along the way
yes
and you definitely will make mistakes i
think part of the calculus for me has
been also
expecting that you're going to allow
small bad things to happen and being
okay with that being okay with it right
because you're never gonna get to like a
hundred percent risk mitigation like
shit's gonna happen
so
being okay with that
sort of the the art of letting small
things small bad things happen to get
the the big good things done yeah
well let me ask just a few more
questions because we're coming up on on
two hours shortly
and uh certainly we can go
anywhere we'd like
and i'm not in any rush i wanted to
mention one thing also when we're
talking about or when you mentioned
committing to things that are five six
nine months out and then having the the
day of reckoning when you look at your
next month and you're like oh for [ __ ]
sake what did i do to myself
i want to say it's esther dyson who's
well-known investor she's i want to say
did cosmonaut training also later in her
life in russia but she
uses this heuristic i think i'm getting
the attribution right where she'll ask
herself if this were next tuesday would
i want to do this thing
and if the answer is no
don't commit to it six months from now
either
uh i think kevin kelly actually borrowed
that from her as well so
question this is one that that uh you've
you've heard before and know i ask a lot
if you could have one billboard
anywhere with anything on it what might
it say what might you put on it could be
image quote question line
just uh metaphorically getting something
out to
many many many millions or billions of
people i've been thinking about this
because i know that you asked this
question
and my original
thought was
who are you but i've modified that i
think a better question is
who are you becoming
and that's a question that
i resisted asking myself for too long
and as a result led me down some dark
pathways or just distracted me from
actualizing in a healthy way
and i think our culture is set up to
to distract us from
that kind of self-inquiry and the reason
that i add the word becoming is i think
that
it speaks to
the
fact that none of us are static like in
every moment
we are shifting and we are changing and
every decision that we make every
interaction that we have every word that
comes out of our mouth
is either moving us towards a better
more
authentic version of ourselves or away
from it in the same way that that
process is as an alcoholic either moving
me towards a drink or away from a drink
so i think in the context of becoming
it's like we're always becoming we're
always on our on our way to becoming
something
are you becoming a better version of
yourself or are you becoming somebody
who is moving away from you know what i
would characterize as as your true
essence and i think the more that we
can inhabit that sensibility if we're in
the habit of like thinking about these
things i think it anchors us
more in
the present moment and allows for more
conscious decisions about how we're
investing our energy and how we're
conducting ourselves or
relating to the world or responding or
reacting to
the world around us i love that
could you repeat it one more time it was
not who am i becoming or is it what type
of person am i becoming who are you
becoming yeah who are you becoming
that's a really good modification i mean
it sort of leads you to telescope out
right looking at whatever the current
decisions and behaviors are it's like
what does this look like in a year what
does this look like in three years what
does this look like in 10 years
good time for me
i'll put that on my
mirror as my wake up reminder that'll be
a good one to add
what are you most excited about for
the next year or what are you excited
about it doesn't have to be the most but
is there anything that comes to mind
what am i most
excited about
that's a hard one or looking forward to
in
the next year i mean i'm looking forward
to my break for sure
uh we have another edition of voicing
change coming out in the new year so i'm
excited there's practical things that
i'm excited about
uh i think i'm but i think what i'm
most excited about is this evolving
shifting
relationship that i have with
the work that i do
and this is something you've talked
about
a lot tim which is
overcoming or transcending this
disposition to
make everything hard you ask this
question like what if it was easy right
and that's a very bitter pill for me to
swallow because my whole life has been
premised on this idea that if if i
haven't suffered to create this thing
that i haven't worked hard enough or
that it doesn't
hold value and i'm in this journey of of
trying to let go
and i've done that through systems and
people here at the podcast but in other
areas of my life to
to
hold the things that i care about
more loosely
and to approach them from that
perspective of
what if it was easy like
i don't have to suffer
to
create like that is an illusion or a
construct that i have
created in my mind and affirmed over
many years but
deconstructing it i realized the fallacy
of it and so trying to
recalibrate my relationship to
the world in which i am able to
like navigate it more from a perspective
of like
grace and joy and allowing rather than
gripping on really tightly is so
counterintuitive
yet also
so liberating while also being
terrifying so i'm not i haven't emerged
from the woods on this yet like this is
definitely like a
you know a hill i might die on but this
is what i'm committed to and this is
part of the intention that i'm bringing
into this month that i'm taking off and
i hope to emerge from that
a little bit more consolidated around
that idea and in a place where i'm ready
to practice it in a way that's more
meaningful than what i have been able to
do historically
that is a good intention
there is a book
that i've been revisiting my kindle
highlights of which is effortless by
greg mcewen
which is the second book
following
essentialism also by greg mcewen but
it's a very nice reminder
along the lines of of what you're
describing because certainly my
i shouldn't say defaults it's probably
conditioned but my sort of
out-of-the-box programming is very
similar uh
to yours it's like if i'm not suffering
if i'm not redlining then clearly i'm
not applying myself enough to whatever x
happens to be
which is just like
so self-defeating in so many ways
so it's it's a constant challenge
however i i have found that uh to be a
very helpful book so i have a tab open
actually on this browser right now on
top left to my to my kindle highlights
of that book so speaking of books your
books include
your best-selling memoir finding ultra
the
cookbooks and lifestyle guides the plant
power way and the plant power away
italia which you co-authored with your
wife
julie
yeah
god over two pay it
good lord i'm sorry julie
forgive me people can find all things
ritual ritual dot com on twitter at
ritual are you most active on twitter
instagram do you have a preferred social
media probably more active on on
instagram than twitter but i'm on both
ritual on instagram as well we'll link
to all of those youtube facebook etc
in the show notes 10. podcast
is there anything else that you would
like to say any closing comments asks or
requests of
this audience
before we
before we wrap up
i mean first of all thank you for having
me it really is a privilege um and and
i've been doing a lot of
thinking around
how divided the world feels right now
and how
broken it can feel there's just so much
contention out there
but when i think about
kind of what we do like having these
long-form conversations it just feels to
me like there's never been a better
opportunity to
contribute in a positive way and you
know i just want to encourage people to
find a way to kind of transcend the
predominant media narrative that seems
hell-bent on pitting us against each
other
and to be more conscious about not just
your media choices but
how you carry that sensibility into the
world in the manner in which you
interact with other people because in my
experience and i'm sure this is shared
by
you know most people like when you go
out into the world it doesn't feel like
what we're seeing on social media and on
the national news like people are
fundamentally good and we share so much
more than what appears to divide us
right now and
i don't know you know i despair of
the way that i hear these
narratives being spun online and so to
me it's almost a reminder of myself to
remember
that what you see there isn't
necessarily a reflection of
the world's objective reality
yeah
here here
so true
and
uh
that is
also
at least for me over the last few weeks
that has been one of the best
medications is the abstaining from
these
inputs that are
very much designed to polarize right
very much designed to upset so that's an
incredibly good reminder and
i really appreciate you taking the time
man i've been looking forward to this
it's landing this conversation is
landing at the perfect time for me
having just come back from this
from this time off the grid with
pages and pages of notes on what i hope
to be big picture
changes or additions or subtractions
that of course are are great in theory
fantastic well done chap you put it all
down on paper but you gotta translate it
somehow so this this uh this i think
will be a nice
push for me
you have a very inspiring story
you also have a
very human story and you have
not just the highlights but you have the
low lights and the difficult times as we
all do and you've been very vulnerable
and
forthcoming in
sharing that full picture with the world
and i think it's such a service uh it's
such a gift
that you do that so
thank you very much for doing what you
do rich i really appreciate it
thanks man i really i appreciate that
and i you know i think vulnerability is
something that you know we can all use a
little bit more of in this world and
when i hear other people being
vulnerable it gives me permission to be
vulnerable
and i think there's real strength in
that so i appreciate that and
i am happy to be somebody to hold you
accountable for this next chapter i'm
excited to see where you know how this
is going to manifest but
i would encourage you to just figure out
something to latch on to so that you can
you know get into action yep and not
just ruminate and make more notes uh and
if you need somebody to you know hold
your hand to the flame on that i'm happy
to be that guy
right so don't spend the next year
deciding which bike to ride i will i'll
do
i will i will do my best so getting
something on the calendar for me if it's
not in the calendar it's and if somebody
else doesn't know about it it's it's
probably
made up so i will
i will i will get something on the
calendar and i'm looking forward to it
i'm really looking forward to it i know
i know it can be done right it's not
it's not the first
time out of the gate actually
putting something together i'm just out
of practice right and
hot damn
stakes and consequences
if people prefer the term incentives
great
they really do work wonders so i'm
looking forward to it and i've really
enjoyed this conversation so thank you
very much rich
and uh to everybody listening we will
have links to everything that we've
discussed in the show notes
at tim.blogs
podcast you can just search ritual and
it'll pop right up you can find him
again at richroll.com
and until next time be safe out there
experiment often
be kinder than you think necessary and
thanks for tuning in
you